before you go how have you been about
three to be reinstated
outspoken online but tight-lipped on his
doorstep this morning Gary lineker back
on air and Keen to get back to normal
his standoff with the BBC ended with
boss Tim Davey apologizing but speaking
with the BBC the director General stood
by his decision to suspend the presenter
I think it was a very big moment in
terms of us saying we have to take stock
here we have to take action we did take
action which we thought was
proportionate
and as the BBC we believe we did the
right thing I think I did the right
thing
having said that I think you have to
look at the balance here and act fairly
the BBC's hand was clearly forced by
what happened here over the weekend its
football coverage decimated after a mass
walkout by its pundits in solidarity
with lineker no final score seemingly
the final straw taking to Twitter
lineker said after a surreal few days
I'm delighted that we have navigated a
way through this I want to thank you all
for the incredible support particularly
my colleagues at BBC sport for the
remarkable show of solidarity less solid
though is the way forward the BBC
announcing an independent review of its
social media policy as it aims to
balance two of its at times conflicting
principles impartiality and free speech
by returning Gary lineker to presenting
duties the BBC has resolved its
short-term problem that we know more
disruption to its Sports Programming but
in the long term fundamental questions
still remain over how it reconciles its
impartiality policy with the tweeting
habits of its high-profile presenters
who don't work in news the BBC managed
to shoot itself in the foot by
suspending Gary which then meant
actually that they were more at risk by
looking like they were giving into a a
culture or Lynch Mob than if they had
simply said to Gary why don't you keep
doing the program and we'll have some
longer term discussions about the way
forward so the BBC managed to end up
with a rather Inglorious position
lineker found himself at the center of
attention after criticizing the
government's Asylum Seeker policy he
will apparently avoid political
controversy going forward but after
tweeting support for refugees once again
today he's unlikely to remain entirely
on the sidelines either Bennett Sky News